hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen
[Music]
today i'm going to take you on a bit of
a vlogging journey with me
as i attempt to resolve my long-standing
sibo
aka small intestinal bacterial
overgrowth
now before we get into it i want to talk
to you about these awesome
new shoes from vessie so i bought so
many shoes
over the years that promise to be
waterproof
and fuss-free only to step in the
teeniest tiniest little puddle and them
to be ruined for life
honestly i'm a mom of two boys puddles
are
kinda our jam but this bessie weekend
shoe
is 100 waterproof sandproof slush proof
and slip proof so they keep my feet
totally dry
and are 100 washable for those really
muddy days
it's actually pretty crazy they're also
vegan
and made with dual climate knit material
that keeps them super comfy and
breathable
and they're surprisingly stylish for
every day plus they're awesome for
travel because they're just so easy
to throw in a bag or to wash i basically
wore these
every single day all spring and summer
long and surprisingly
i can still wear them into the winter
with all of our canadian
rain slush and snow so especially for
the upcoming rainy season
vessies are my go-to shoes so check them
out at the link below
and use my code to get 25 off of your
vessy shoes
now before we get into it you can read
my disclaimer on screen
and in the description below including a
huge reminder
that any of the foods or supplements
that i take
or the tests that i do are not i repeat
not recommendations for the masses
this is also not meant to be a long-term
diet or lifestyle by any means and my
needs on this journey will always be
changing
depending on what my blood work says and
what my
symptoms suggest so as always
definitely speak to a dietitian trained
in digestive health for your
personalized care
and in fact i'm gonna be linking to some
of my colleagues below
in the description who provided me with
some clinical insights
all right so first of all a wee
background
if y'all watched my video on bloating
and my low fodmap video
you know that i've been struggling with
my digestion since pregnancy and giving
birth
and sadly it's just getting worse after
identifying that i have some
pretty significant diastasis recti
then doing a low fodmap trial and
identifying some of my triggers
yet not getting full relief i spoke to
my doctor
gi dietitian gind and gastroenterologist
and we decided that it was a good idea
to get me test for sibo
next so very quickly what the heck is
sibo
well small intestinal bacterial growth
aka
sibo is exactly what it sounds like
it's an excessive amount of bacteria in
the small intestine
so there are two main types of sibo
methane dominant bacteria and hydrogen
dominant bacteria
and each have slightly different
symptoms but generally speaking
sibo can cause fatigue weakness
constipation
diarrhea abdominal distension bloating
and
gas some people with severe sibo
actually showcase with a very swollen
almost pregnant like belly and sibo is
often
also present with other ibs related
conditions so
it is often misdiagnosed or even missed
so what generally causes sibo well
sometimes we don't actually know the
exact cause but it's usually related to
inadequate gastric secretions
or motility issues in the small
intestine often linked to
medication use like antibiotics food
poisoning
ibs or dysfunction of certain organs
next how do we even test for sibo
thankfully there is a diagnostic
breath test so basically when bacteria
digest food
they produce gases that we can then
later breathe out
so to test for sibo we consume a
substrate that the bacteria can feast on
usually a fodmap like laculos
and then we test our breath at different
intervals to see
how much hydrogen and methane is being
exhaled
now these levels can tell the doctor
where bacteria are fermenting
in your intestinal system and also how
much gas they're creating
from eating the lactulose so that
brings me right here to the test which
was shipped to me
for about 250 and if that
didn't suck enough the pre-test diet
definitely did for 48 hours i was
limited to
literally just a handful of virtually
fiber-free
fodmap free foods and drinks honestly
the approved list of foods is
really arbitrary in my professional
opinion and different practitioners are
more or less strict but i was basically
told i could only have
like plain chicken fish or eggs with
salt and pepper only
plain white rice plain white bread bone
broth
cooking oil and black coffee or tea yep
i wanted to die i basically ate the
exact same thing both days because
well there wasn't a whole lot of room
for creativity
and it was just so depressing to try to
come up with something
new to make without any vegetables
fruit spices or condiments but yeah it
was rough
especially without my morning latte
all right so not super enthusiastic
about
the black coffee i am not a black coffee
drinker
i don't know how people do that might
just be a couple
exhaustion struggle days yeah cause i'm
not sure i'm gonna get that down
i'm just gonna do black tea today which
is
also not really my favorite thing but
i can't bring myself to do that black
coffee again so
bottoms up but i did try to chef up
some eggs and toast as best as i could
it definitely would have been better
with some butter or some avocado or
peanut butter
but i really just try to focus on it
being
nourishment and like look forward to
just having a real meal
that i could enjoy a few days later for
snacks i had
really basic things like hard-boiled
eggs bone broth and a pan fried
sourdough with
lots of fleur de sel i think i ate
like a loaf of bread that day because i
guess like obviously white bread is not
very saturating
and side note bone broth isn't actually
too bad
i mean i don't think that i would
probably have consumed it if i wasn't
starving
but in my moment of desperation at least
i guess it tasted okay as for my other
meals
for my lunch i made some super sad
chicken tacos if you will while my kids
of course got to eat all the guacamole
and beans and salsa
on theirs cue the major food envy
yeah and i know it's not really a taco
without guac or salsa
but i was like trying to play make
believe
i kind of felt like the lost boys in
that iconic scene in hook with
the late robin williams like when they
were eating that
incredible invisible feast but
ultimately
at least it kind of filled my belly then
for dinner i
did some chicken fried rice which again
was like really sad
without any vegetables or garlic or soy
sauce going on
especially when i had to serve my family
the real deal which actually looked and
smelled
really good so yeah the boredom with the
meals
did suck i am so thirsty i feel like
because the only
flavor that i can add to my food is the
flavor of salt
i'm adding a lot of salt and that means
i'm
like downing the water at this point
the hardest part for sure was the 12
hour complete overnight fast before the
test which was actually
15 hours by the time that the test was
actually done obviously
this isn't an inordinate amount of time
for a lot of people to go without eating
before some kind of procedure
but this is not normal for a
hungry breastfeeding mama who is eating
super low fiber carbs that do not keep
one full
it was torture when i woke up to pump at
2 am
i was so ravenous and i couldn't fall
back asleep
so yeah i was super annoyed but let's
talk about the upside
of this torturous exercise and that was
that after
two days of eating just like plain
refined white carbs
my bloating distension and gas
completely gone
it was instant relief but i was left
with this other strange discomfort
like almost like i was constipated but i
don't think i did this long enough to
actually
get constipated so that's good but it
wasn't a pleasant feeling either
i also felt really deeply unsatisfied
and honestly i must have actually been
under eating
as a result of just not wanting to eat
any more rice or chicken
because my breast milk supply also
tanked those days
but finally we made it to test day and i
was
very eager to get started i am so hungry
i am so hungry so all i can think about
is like
digging into that big salad at lunch
this is why i cannot do like i could
never do intermittent fasting
especially now while breastfeeding
because i wake up in the middle of the
night
and i am ravenous
hangry it actually was really hard for
me to get back to sleep because i was
just like
thinking about eating but the sooner i
get started on this test
the sooner i get to have lunch so let's
do it
okay hold the easy sampler device in one
hand and the collection tube in the
other do not insert the tube
yet take a normal deep breath in now
deep breath
close your mouth exhale
bottoms up not the latte i was looking
forward to this morning but
better than plain water i guess
i feel like i'm having flashbacks to
high school
if you know what i mean
last one and i cannot tell you how
excited i am to eat
um and just like counting down the
seconds but also
praying that my baby doesn't wake up
right as i'm trying to
have my breakfast lunch here
because i'll be upset i'm probably gonna
have to let him cry until i finish
eating because
that's how hungry i am right now let's
do it
success right on cue
i gotta i'm gonna have to let him cry
here because
i was just dying for cereal oatmeal
with cereal on top finally it was time
to eat something with color in it
and of course my geeky dietitian veg
cravings
were fierce i just had the most uh
random lunch of life but most
importantly
i had salad which i was dying for
some crunchy that's what i was missing i
just realized that
everything i was eating over the past
two days was like the same
soft texture i needed some crunch
whether that was cereal so i had like
tons of cereal this morning and i had
cereal for
lunch with like a huge bowl of greek
yogurt and like more granola
cereal on top and fruit all the things
that i haven't eaten the last two days
because the last thing i was gonna do
was eat chicken and eggs and rice
and bread because that's all i've eaten
and it was getting damn boring
so i feel super happy and content
but i also feel pretty bloated and full
and i was like
hmm when you see the total juxtaposition
you're like i see where the problem lies
it's probably the vegetables so i'm
probably gonna
figure out like a middle ground where i
am not so bloated but i'm also not
miserable so yeah test submitted all
good
and then we hit a curveball so
i just got a call that my test
is void because and canceled because
some of the vials got broken in transit
so that means that i have to do this all
over again next week
to say i'm disappointed
would be an understatement yeah and it's
honestly already been a really
happy day because i've just been dealing
with oh
having a major meltdown i don't know if
it's like a leap but he basically has
not slept all day and he's just cried
all day
so anyways i guess i will be
hangry and exhausted from
lack of coffee that i like i'm not gonna
lie
i cried that day i cried a lot that day
it was actually just a really day and
that was just the
icing on the cake the cake that for once
i did not want to eat
but i also didn't want to waste any more
time so i got a new test kit and i
batch prepped a ton of rice and i went
at it
again honestly if there was something
new and fun to eat that i could share
with you here
i would have filmed it for you but that
was the problem
there was nothing new or fun to eat
i think i'm a pretty creative cook but
there's really only so much you can do
with like
five meh ingredients so at a lack of
inspiration
i basically just made the exact same
thing but i had
bigger portions of everything and i
think i ate like a half a loaf of bread
before the 15 hour fast before bed
even after eating more calories than
usual
i was still hungry at night which i
guess is a really great reminder to us
all
to eat our fiber fiber
is just so important for promoting
satiety while eating food that you
actually
like is so important for that emotional
satisfaction factor as well
neither of which i was getting on this
diet
but anyways i got her done and was on to
another day of tests
and this time i was gonna make damn sure
that nothing was gonna break so then
it was a waiting game
so i just got the call i got my results
back and not surprising they
are positive and you think i was like
upset about this like a positive
diagnosis for anything is usually
kind of a scary deal but in this case it
means that
you know there's something there and
there's something we can do about it
um and there's actual you know
medications that can help treat this
it's not just necessarily something i'm
gonna have to live with
for the rest of my life like something
just like straight up
mysterious like ibs so i'm actually
really relieved and my results showed
that
it was actually methane bacteria
dominant which was
which was surprising to me based on my
symptoms
because methane bacteria usually results
in
more constipation whereas hydrogen
bacteria
tends to be more diarrhea tmi
i know but that's typically what we see
clinically
but the hydrogen bacteria can actually
be masked when
methane bacteria is present because the
methane bacteria feeds on the hydrogen
bacteria
which can make the hydrogen numbers look
lower than they actually are so it's
actually quite possible that i have a
bit of both
but anyways the treatment in this case
is the same so i'm really looking
forward to
getting started on the protocol so my
official sibo treatment plan
was to be as follows i would start the
process with
two weeks on a biofilm disruptor now
biofilm is
an extracellular matrix that protects
the bacteria
from stressors like an antibiotic so
think of it like the beehive protecting
the colony inside
you ideally want to break down the
biofilm before you attack the colony so
to speak
and side note before you come at me i'm
not suggesting
that we kill bees i love bees we need
bees but we don't need
sibo anyways there ultimately aren't a
lot of breastfeeding safe
options right now so we opted to use an
acetylcysteine aka
nak which is a more gentle disruptor
than some pharmaceutical options on the
market
next after two weeks trying to break
down the biofilm
i was to begin a two-week protocol of an
antibiotic called rifaximin
plus an herbal microbial called allymax
pro
which is basically a high potency
allicin supplement
which has been shown to help with sibo
particularly methane dominant sibo
as an adjunct again there are stronger
options for this
since most people do need to be taking
two antibiotics to really kill off the
bacteria
but of course they aren't safe in
pregnancy
so we had to take like a gentler root
now this was actually the fun part
because it meant that i got to eat a lot
of the fodmaps that i've been
pulling back on since the theory goes
that
well-fed bacteria are more active
and therefore easier to kill now you'll
also find practitioners who recommend
the opposite
and that is to starve the bacteria but
generally
this is a recommendation for folks doing
an all-natural
herbal protocol which typically will
take
a bit longer to see results anyways
i happily ate my cauliflower
and watermelon and broccoli and brussels
sprouts
and my spicy barbecue baked beans and
gazpacho with so much raw garlic in it
that it would kill a vampire
and man it felt
so good emotionally
and also physically as well oh my god
guys
total tmi here but holy no pun intended
i did not know that so much poop could
come out
of a human and it feels amazing
i actually feel like i've got a better
appetite now as well because i have just
like
more room in my stomach for food
and i also don't feel so sluggish after
every single meal i'm not going to show
you like comparative body shots because
i don't want
this video to be just like about getting
a flat stomach but i will say that my
stomach is like
noticeably different as well i actually
just assumed that my stomach was just
like
my post baby belly slash uterus and i
was always like totally fine with that i
am
in awe at what my body has done and
accomplished
but i'm actually now starting to realize
that you know what
a lot of that was probably or is
probably
bloating so yeah this has been a
remarkable
difference here and i'm just hoping that
it keeps up and it really did after two
weeks of treatment i was
feeling super great and probably about
60 percent better
so we decided to do another two weeks of
treatment
to kill off the rest of bacteria but
that's when
it started to go downhill so
i'm on my third week so basically the
second round of antibiotics
and it's like they're not working but
i'm definitely plateauing
like i i was doing this in terms of
feeling better and now i'm doing
so i mean i don't know what's going on
i'm taking the same drug you'd think
that
things would continue to move in a
positive way but looks like we've
reached
a plateau and i was never able to
feel that good again after the fourth
week i moved on to the third
maintenance stage which was to come off
of the antibiotics and start a
prokinetic agent to promote motility and
prevent the bacteria from pooling
and flourishing basically a prokinetic
stimulates and coordinates
gastrointestinal motility to help
support
what we call the migratory motor complex
or mmc so the mmc moves bacteria
down the large intestine every 130
minutes or so
between meals and not having an adequate
or strong enough
mmc is thought to play a role in sibo
because the bacteria can basically hang
out
and populate in the bowel so we went
with ginger as our prokinetic because
the pharmaceutical options again
aren't safe in breastfeeding and ginger
does have some evidence to support its
use
in reducing sibo unfortunately this is
when things
really started to tank so i just
finished
the second round of the antibiotics so
four weeks and it's like my body
just got used to and enjoyed the royal
treatment
and completely shut down like i'm really
constipated right now and i am
never constipated constipation is not my
issue
i'm also seemingly reacting to like
fodmap
foods that were not an issue before like
dairy when i did my low fodmap
elimination trial dairy did not come up
as one of my main triggers like i've
always been fine with dairy
i love dairy but now i have a single
spoonful of cottage cheese
or a spoonful of ice cream
and i'm in rough shape even if i take a
lactate
so i don't not know what's going on
right now also i had like a few pieces
of cauliflower off my kids plate last
night and i was in the fetal position
all night in pain so yeah that was a
tease
that was an honestly brutal tease
and i don't know where we go from here
that felt like a
real blow i had finally gotten a taste
of freedom where i wasn't in pain
or discomfort every night before bed and
it all just got
ripped away super depressing i'm not
gonna lie
so yeah i basically just waited for my
appointment to find out next steps
i just got off the phone with the doctor
and
honestly i can't say i'm not
disappointed with our plan
basically what may be happening why i'm
kind of experiencing
this kind of plateau and also some
symptoms
um coming that i never had before is
that it's possible that the biofilm
disruptor is just not strong enough to
really get to
those deep mature colonies
and therefore the antibiotic couldn't
quite kill them off
but now those more mature colonies are
aggravated and they're angry
and that may be why i'm now suddenly
reacting to
certain fodmaps that i never reacted to
before so
you like dairy so it's not like i'm
lactose intolerant
it's just that those more mature
colonies
are now kind of exposed and are
feasting on the dairy and those fodmaps
now unfortunately all of my other
options for
biofilm disruptors and antibiotics and
prokinetics
are not considered safe while
breastfeeding
so yeah typical mom dilemma here i'm
faced with the very
hard decision on whether or not to take
care of my health
or to continue to breastfeed my son
yeah it's a really hard call but i think
i'm gonna have to put this
journey on pause until i'm ready to wean
or my son's ready to wean
and i'm sure he'd be totally fine to
switch to formula
or or cow's milk at this stage i i don't
know that i'm ready
just to end that journey too
you know i fought so hard to breastfeed
oh
so i'm not sure that i'm ready i mean i
may re-evaluate if this gets really bad
and we can we might just start this
process up real quick again
but for now i'm probably gonna have to
take a little bit of a break
so as we wait for that day to come i'm
taking on a few additional supplements
to help support my digestion
one is a probiotic which is a little
controversial
since the concern is that you're adding
bacteria to an
overgrowth that's already there which
obviously is not what you want
but really early research does suggest
that probiotic supplements
can be effective as a sibo treatment
both as a standalone
and as like a follow-up treatment so the
three most beneficial strains of sibo
probiotics to look out for
are bifidus infantis bifidus lactus
and lactobacillus plantarum next i have
added
in a different prokinetic called
iberogast
which also has some good research to
support its use
so i'm taking that with my meals and i'm
also taking
one ginger capsule in the morning when i
wake up i'm also still taking my
patent hcl and my meals to ensure
adequate stomach acid for proper
digestion
and anytime i'm eating things with dairy
in it
i'm taking a lactate and if i'm eating
beans
i'll take a beano supplement just to be
safe
now the biggest and hardest adjustment
however
has been shifting the timing of my meals
and snacks
as a mom i think i've gotten into the
habit of like
constantly putting things into my mouth
all day hey
that's what she said but every time i do
that
even if it's just like a little bite of
my son's leftover sandwich
or a few berries i disrupt the migratory
motor complex which then makes it easier
for bacteria to pool and populate so
it's been really
quite a challenge for me because i am by
nature
such a grazer which may or may not have
been related to my sibo in the first
place
i also sometimes wonder if i'm by nature
more of a
grazer and like to have those multiple
smaller meals in the day because
eating a lot in one sitting feels
bloating to me
but regardless i am actively aiming now
to have
bigger sit-down meals and waiting about
three hours before i have another meal
or snack it's probably gonna take
a while for my body to adjust to this
routine
and it is requiring me to think a lot
more about food and eating
than i would like to but i am just
hoping that with time
this will become my normal routine
and more importantly i hope it actually
gives me some relief
okay update guys i don't know what's
going on but i'm feeling
so much better i it just kind of
happened out of the blue
and i'm not sure which supplement it was
or you know
which shift in my routine or if it's
everything all at once
but i actually feel like i'm almost
back to my antibiotic phase digestion if
you know what i'm saying
and it feels so good
and i'm back to tolerating dairy again i
don't know what the hell
happened there uh which is really
important because i got a
ton of ben jerry's in the freezer and a
dq ice cream cake that i need to enjoy
this summer
so thank you very much dairy gods
and i'm also tolerating like moderate
amounts of fodmaps as well
now i have admittedly made an effort to
really cut back on like my salad intake
so i'm eating most of my vegetables
either in like a smoothie but mainly
like a cooked vegetable side dish
but i have found that even on the
occasion that i have had a little salad
at dinner
it hasn't caused the same level of
bloating
at nighttime like it had been before so
this is promising this is feeling
good and this is really gross oh my gosh
yeah i think we'll probably do a retest
after i'm done nursing just to see where
i'm netting out and see if there's any
additional improvements that maybe could
be made
with another course of antibiotics but
until then i'm feeling good so i guess
this video is
tbd and maybe in the fall we can pick
this back up with another leg of this
journey
and maybe just maybe
i can ease off some of the restrictions
and supplements
it'll be really nice to be able to be a
little bit more flexible with my eating
and snacking schedule throughout the day
but i guess for now i will just kind of
relish in a sweet little victory
that is being able to tolerate dairy
again
ben jerry's get at me boys
and on that note another big thank you
to my colleagues andrea hardy aaron
judge
and ali coogler for helping me navigate
this topic
and answering some of my questions as
they are the experts in this field
again i'm going to leave their contacts
below in case you're interested in
getting some more one-on-one advice
and hearing more about what they can
offer and on that note if you like this
video be sure to give it
the thumbs up leave me a comment below
on any other vlog content or topics you
want me to make a video about
subscribe to the channel and i'll see
you next time on abby's kitchen
bye and for more great videos like this
check out the link right here
you